we're a strong United and tight-knit
community the highly anticipated sequel
to Disney Channels zombies finally aired
on February 14th
2020 Dom B's 2 was a lot of fun with new
songs and great new characters wanna
know how Milo Manheim and Meg Donnelly
felt about that on-screen smooch keep
watching to find out all the
behind-the-scenes secrets we have a
brilliant and cheer tested candidate
running for president this year building
a movie is hard work actors spend long
hours on set during filming they have to
film each scene several times to get it
absolutely perfect it's even more
difficult when there are lots of huge
dance numbers like in zombies - even
though filming was a lot of fun for the
cast they had to work really hard after
a full month of rehearsals they started
filming but a lot of the movie happens
at night after all there are werewolves
and zombies in Seabrook they aren't
known for hanging out during the day
many of the night scenes took hours to
film even if they were only a couple of
minutes long this led to overnight
filming sessions the cast would be up
all night and sometimes the cast - just
hung around at night if they weren't in
those scenes they really just enjoyed
being with each other
meg hung out when she wasn't needed on
Trevor Tordjman 's last day on set but
there are a lot of daytime shots - how
did the cast manage to catch some Z's
[Music]
Milo Manheim plays the world's greatest
zombie as Zed he's a great friend
athlete and big brother he's also a
really great dancer
Milo impressed everyone with his dance
moves in the first movie but then he
impressed the rest of the world when he
appeared on Dancing with the Stars in
2018 Milo was paired with professional
dancer Witney Carson the pair came in
second place on the show
Milo showed off his new dance moves
behind the scenes of zombies - according
to Megan his other co-stars he sauces
every five seconds it's great Meg told
j14 magazine that she thinks his dance
moves got even better after being on the
competition show but that didn't stop
her from teasing him in Milo's
behind-the-scenes video he said Meg
likes to do an impression of his dance
moves it was pretty hilarious but he got
her back these two best friends aren't
afraid to tease each other a little it's
all in good fun from everything the cast
has said it sounds like zombies - was a
blast to film it really helps when they
are all great friends j14 magazine sat
down with mag Donnelly pierce Josa
Arielle Martin and Chandler Kinney they
asked Megan the new actors about their
funniest moments on set apparently they
all spent their time laughing trevor
Tordjman who plays bucky is apparently
one of the funniest members of the cast
he likes to riff an improv when he's off
camera meg would cry from laughing so
hard
trevor has great comedic timing meg also
thought that it was hilarious watching
everyone dive into the mud for the song
we got this it was funny for the fans to
another hilarious moment behind the
scenes happened at dance rehearsals in
the last week of rehearsals the werewolf
dancers had to get used to dancing in
their wigs so they came to practice in
normal clothes and makeup while wearing
giant werewolf wigs the actor said it
looks so funny since no one else was in
costume one of the most powerful scenes
in zombies - is the dance number for
flesh and bones this song was amazing it
was all about standing
yourself in loving yourself for who you
are we're all more than flesh and bones
the song also had some deep political
messages to Milo Manheim revealed that
this song means the most to him out of
all of them it's a really emotional song
his character Zed has a lot of fear he
realizes that he hates being a monster
when she takes out on Addison he has to
get over that Milo said that flesh and
bones was the turning point for his
character that's when Zed realizes that
the werewolves are more than just
monsters and so is he he really turns
his attitude around after that and fixes
his bad decisions we can really see his
character turn it around - Milo poured
all of his emotions into that number
you're fierce proud werewolves they
think we're monsters we are monsters
every time we see a cast in an interview
they act like they are all best friends
but it's more than acting the cast of
zombies is really close how did they get
to be such good friends
the answer is game night in the first
movie the cast often had dance parties
together they continued that tradition
but I don't a bunch of Borg games to the
mix they all stayed at the same hotel so
they would get together and play games
they started this from the very
beginning of rehearsals everyone talks
about how much fun these nights were the
number one game that they played was
Bananagrams
the cast also had pool parties honestly
it sounds like filming zombies too was a
blast if they were not playing games or
spending time at the pool
they were always hanging out they'd even
go to the grocery store together just to
get some snacks the original cast
welcomed the new werewolves into the
fold right away Meg invited Pierce to
hang out the very first night they met
they were in the elevator and she asked
if he was coming to her room to hang out
he was a little taken aback but he
joined the rest of the cast he was part
of the pack from that night on
one of the themes from the first movie
was standing out from the status quo
Seabrook was all about conformity that
theme of individuality continued on in
zombies too but when you're filming
choreograph dance numbers it's hard to
be an individual everyone is doing the
same moves right not in zombies to the
choreographers and directors wanted
everyone's personality to shine through
the dance numbers they have the same
basic moves but they were free to add
their own personal spin everyone had
their own variation that made these
dance numbers even better this personal
touch extended into the costuming
Department the werewolves didn't fit in
with the humans or the zombies they are
totally unique
so Pearce Arielle and Chandler got to
have input in their costumes they had to
wear certain items but then they were
allowed to spice it up for their
characters we loved how much artistic
expression the actors were able to
uphold Zen Addison finally kissed in
zombies - but filming this on-screen
Peck wasn't easy keep watching for all
the details it can be daunting to be the
new kid on the block Arielle Martin said
that she had a lot of anxiety about
joining the cast she knew how close-knit
everyone was and then she had a delay
when getting to Toronto for rehearsals
she showed up three days late which made
her feel even more anxious she was
worried about not knowing the
choreography and how everyone would
treat her but she didn't have to worry
at all when she arrived Meg texted her
to welcome her to Canada Arielle told
Seventeen magazine that that helped a
lot she got to rehearsals early the next
day and ran into Chandler Pierce and Meg
they showed her the choreography that
she missed a so she wouldn't fall behind
the next day Arielle joined them for her
first game night
once they spent time hanging out she no
longer felt worried about fitting in it
definitely helped that her co-stars were
so nice and helpful our past is our pack
we don't need anyone else so it wasn't
just the older cast members that would
hang out together it can be hard to be
younger than a lot of people on set
Kingston Foster who plays Zoe in the
movies is only nine years old most of
her co-stars are in their teens or early
twenties but they didn't make her feel
left out at all
Kingston bonded really well with the
werewolf actresses Arie
and Chandler she had a girls night with
them they baked cookies from scratch and
had a ton of fun she also said that they
would play a game where there were spies
on set we think it's great that the
older actors worked hard to include
Kingston and who can blame them she's an
awesome kid when you're playing a
werewolf you need a lot of makeup and
sometimes stage makeup can be a real
hassle here's Joseph who plays Wyatt
said that his makeup test took seven
hours for the test they try to figure
out what works and what doesn't and
creating a werewolf takes a long time he
spent literally a full day in the makeup
chair while the makeup artists work
their magic
it didn't take seven hours every time
but putting on the werewolf makeup still
took a couple of hours everyday Pearce
also got freaked out by the acrylic
nails he was having a rough day and
hadn't eaten he didn't realize that they
glue giant acrylics on your nails before
they trim them he's said he nearly
passed out when he saw how long they
were and what about those glowing
werewolf eyes often actors will wear
colored contacts but not everyone can
handle them the movie avoided that issue
altogether the creepy eyes were all
added in post-production by video
editors okay this is a little bit weird
fans were so excited that Zed and
Addison finally had their first kiss it
was so sweet and romantic but they were
just acting there's nothing romantic
about filming this sort of scene Milo
and Meg are best friends in real life
thankfully that made them feel relaxed
instead of awkward but the logistics of
kissing on-screen are difficult it has
to look perfect on camera meg said that
they probably kissed about eight times
to get it just right in one take her
nose look too squished in another his
face was almost entirely covering hurts
they had to work hard to line up their
lips to get the perfect shot yeah that's
definitely not romantic it may have
taken them several tries but they
finally got it their on-screen smooch
was perfect even though it was one of
the last scenes in the movie it was shot
the first weekend of filming they got it
out of the way so it wasn't looming over
them what was your favorite moment from
zombies too let us know
comments below thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the things see
you next time